welcome to episode 40 of the michaela
peterson podcast
i spoke with dr james d nicole antonio
the author of
the salt fix the immunity fix
co-authored by sim land the longevity
solution
we spoke about salt of course the unfair
demonization of salt the benefits of
electrolytes
speaking of which the electrolytes i've
been working on for the last
year are finally to my satisfaction they
are very tasty
they're very good but more on that later
i think they're going to be coming out
around march but i'll keep you posted in
this episode
dr denis antonio also sidetracked me
into
a mask and vaccine discussion but that
ended up being kind of fun
this episode is brought to you by true
local tru
local the company i've been partnered
with for the last couple of years
they get their meat from local farmers
and you can design a customized box on
their website
and get it shipped flash frozen to you i
like them specifically because their
steaks are actually good
and super marbled see here sorry to
everybody just listening but
i'm showing a super marbled steak that's
super marbled
their lamb is great their turkey thighs
are great their wild salmon's great with
code mp
you can get free steaks added to a large
box
great for avoiding neurotic grocery
shopping that's going on
for getting healthier eat your meat and
for getting access to high quality
sustainably raised and local meat from a
small company
that checks a lot of boxes i hope you
enjoy this episode
and if you do please remember to rate
and hit subscribe and check out my
weekly newsletter
[Music]
dr d nicole antonio welcome to my
podcast
thanks for having me i'm michaela i'm
super excited to talk
i have both your books so you have the
salt fix
which is and then you have the newer the
immunity fix
so i'd like to i have a whole bunch of
questions for
both of those but can we start by you
giving my audience a brief background
about who you are and what it is that
you do
sure so i'm a cardiovascular research
scientist with st
luke's mid-america heart institute and i
also am the associate editor of british
medical journals open heart which is
the largest open access uk cardiology
journal
in partnership with the british
cardiovascular society
and i have been publishing on
nutrition nutraceuticals cardiovascular
health for over a decade
i have about 250 academic publications
and um sort of a lot of those
publications have led
me to writing those books and include a
lot of information from my studies
in those books yeah i think i heard
about you i heard about you a long time
ago
i think for the salt fix because you
were the doctor that was saying
hey salt's actually necessary it's good
for you it shouldn't be demonized
uh and i i think i heard about you
before i even started
dieting in 2015. so you've been around
for a while
yeah i've been in the game for a bit
yeah yeah
okay so let's start off um i want to
cover salt first
because i've found i've had some
interesting experiences
um playing around with the amount of
salt i
eat and i have a whole bunch of
questions to throw at you so let's start
with
um one why why is it that salt has been
demonized
that's a good question and primarily
it's based on people with high blood
pressure
and solely looking at small reductions
in blood pressure for that group
and extrapolating those small potential
benefits
um to the general population which we
should never have done
and so essentially if you have normal
blood pressure
uh 80 of people are not salt sensitive
uh whereas
if you have high blood pressure about
one in two people are salt sensitive
okay
and so they extrapolate that that harm
in 50
of those people which is a minority of
the population to the general population
and they never looked at the harms of
low salt which if you actually look
uh even those people with high blood
pressure get increases in heart rate
uh low blood volume increases in stress
hormones like noradrenaline aldosterone
and so when you actually multiply heart
rate by blood pressure which is
indicative of the stress on the heart
even people with high blood pressure low
salt diets seem to
stress the heart out and so simply
looking at one surrogate marker
blood pressure in one particular group
and demonizing
this essential mineral okay so just to
reiterate
people who are more prone to high blood
pressure or already suffer from high
blood pressure
if they have a high salt diet can that
make it worse
yeah so if you have a high salt intake
and you already have like you know let's
say
a significant increase in blood pressure
from that in the book though i discussed
that
in probably 80 of those people it's
driven by a diet high in refined carbs
and sugar
and due to the elevated insulin levels
so if you just drop those
you know refined carbs and sugar fix
your insulin level
you can essentially improve or fix that
salt sensitivity about 80
of those people now in the small
percentage of the other people
there's other potential you know
confounding factors they may have
elevated aldosterone for multiple
reasons
or they may have um other issues high
cortisol
driving the salt sensitivity so you got
to just fix the underlying
issue in most of the cases it's very
rare that a normal salt intake is a
problem even for people who are quote
unquote salt sensitive
i will say though that if you overdo
salt and you're not getting enough
potassium and magnesium which helps us
control salt
then you can experience some side
effects okay so what's the ideal ratio
for
sodium potassium magnesium
so i mean just like with anything in
life especially with an essential
mineral
you have like this u-shaped curve and it
depends on the person but there's always
going to be this u-shaped curve where
if you get too low of this essential
mineral you have adverse effects and
you've got to find that perfect optimal
amount where
you're getting most of the benefits and
little side effects and then you can get
too much
for the average person what all the
prospective studies
show is that consuming around one and a
half teaspoons of salt
per day is likely ideal which is
associated with the lowest risk of heart
attacks cardiovascular disease and
all-cause mortality
and yet every single clinical guideline
tells us to consume less than a teaspoon
of salt
wow wow i certainly don't do that
uh okay why is it that when people
transition to a low-carb diet a lot of
them feel better increasing their salt
take intake so essentially
when you reduce those refined
carbohydrates
you drop insulin and insulin helps the
kidneys retain salt
and so when you have low insulin levels
you start spilling salt and fluid
out in the urine but also chronically
why a lot of people feel like they need
more salt
is not due to the one week or so where
you're losing
about an extra half a teaspoon to a
teaspoon of salt in the urine
but chronically glucose helps us absorb
salt in the intestine and so when you're
not consuming glucose your absorption of
salt is also down
and so that's why a lot of people
actually need salt and feel better
chronically eating it oh that's so
interesting i didn't
i didn't know that i've done a lot of
reading on salt i did not know that
about glucose
that's very cool i know i know a lot of
people who start the low carb diet
feel better like i said increasing their
sodium intake increasing their potassium
intake if that doesn't work
increasing their magnesium intake and
i'd like to talk to you specifically
about magnesium because you've been
doing a lot of work with
magnesium l three and eight so can you
give can you give us a bit of a
background about what the differences
between the different
magnesiums are and what are the benefits
what what should we be doing
sure so from sort of like an
evolutionary perspective
the estimates have been anywhere from we
used to consume around 600 to maybe a
thousand milligrams of magnesium
and over the last 80 years or so the
average drop of magnesium and vegetables
has been about 35
and in animal foods about 15 to 20 so
just from uh
unless you're consuming foods from a
regenerative farm you're already
consuming foods that are lower in
magnesium and the typical average
american adult
is only consuming around 200 to 250
milligrams so
we're sort of like at this evolutionary
mismatch of
uh lacking anywhere from like 250 to 400
milligrams
of magnesium compared to what we used to
get
and so right there that sort of sets us
to sort of need more
if we're not consuming foods from let's
say regenerative farms
and essentially the different forms the
most common magnesium supplement is
citrate
which is actually a laxative and so if
you have if you're constipated citrate
is great
but if you're trying to actually elevate
magnesium status
it's not going to be your best magnesium
essentially magnesium
bioavailability is its ability to
solubilize and ionize which means
it dissolves in water and has a charged
particle
that's how we primarily absorb magnesium
you can hack that by binding it to small
amino acids like glycine to get the
magnesium molecule
into the body um through amino acid
transporters
but essentially um things like magnesium
oxide which is another common
over-the-counter magnesium supplement
isn't very soluble so it doesn't ionize
very well a lot of it's bound and you
poop a lot of it up
um whereas magnesium l3 and 8 is very
soluble and
ionizes and so it absorbs very well now
the difference between
things like the chelated magnesiums that
are bound to glycine that have good
bioavailability
we don't know how well they get into the
cell so
again inside the body the magnesium
needs to turn into ionic magnesium ions
to then get into the cell
and so if you have a magnesium bound to
glycine which has a fairly
um high you know there's something
called the dissociation factor
but it doesn't really dissociate very
well so you got to get it into the cell
and the difference between 3 and 8 and
glistening is that 3n8 is the only
molecule that has been shown to crop be
able to cross the blood-brain barrier
and get into the actual neuron and there
have been clinical studies shown that
magnesium health renate improves um
cognition reduces brain aging by nine
years and people with cognitive
dysfunction
um and the reason why magnesium can do
this bound to three and eight
we think is there's these glucose
transporters they're called glute
transporters
and the whole magnesium three and eight
molecule can
sort of get into those glute
transporters through the blood-brain
barrier and then into the neuron
and other magnesium supplements don't
seem to have that ability
interesting so what what about something
like epsom salts baths
like what are the benefits there so
that's more of a top
topical local effect and so there's a
huge myth out there that you can absorb
magnesium
uh through the skin into the blood but
you can't if you could you would die
every time
you went into the ocean and we would
explode as well we would die from salt
toxicity if we actually could absorb
minerals through our skin
um so that doesn't happen but locally
topically
epsom salts have been found to have like
a muscle relaxant type of effect
it's more anecdotal but um it's not
going to boost your overall let's say
magnesium status
okay uh and then things like so taking
my magnesium glycinate you said was
probably a better idea than taking
magnesium citrate but magnesium l3n8 is
probably the most
absorbable at least for the brain yeah
for the brain right so
what if you're what do you do if you're
experiencing muscle cramps
that might not be magnesium per se but
not
right so you get like to get i mean i
get that question all the time so many
people have muscle spasms
i had them brutally when i went to the
carnivore diet about five months in
like they woke me up at night and i was
like what i've been doing okay five
months in they were so bad
especially on my like bad leg that they
were waking me up
at night and eventually they stopped but
it actually coincided with
uh a i think i had massively
increased my salt intake um at that
point
uh just for taste uh so i think it
coincided with that but i'm not sure so
what are your recommendations for people
dealing with that
yeah so i mean i guess it depends right
on what's causing it so
i think there is this balance where you
can overdo salt
and not getting enough salt
and so i think both actually can lead to
muscle cramps
and same thing with with low potassium
or low magnesium
that both of those can also lead to
muscle cramps
yeah so you basically the person is
going to have to play around increase
one decrease another yeah it's tricky to
figure out
uh you mentioned regenerative farming
and that there's more magnesium
specifically in meat from regenerative
farms how does that work
yeah so essentially um well how we've
grown
our crops we'll just we'll take a look
at crops for example
instead of using like traditional manure
we now use chemical fertilizers which
inhibit the uptake of nutrients
including magnesium
and so we also now grow for yield
and so we're growing crops quicker and
so they are growing fast and not able to
take up the nutrients
as quickly and so essentially they're
nutrient depleted they're diluted
because of how
quickly they're we're growing these
hybrid crops so it's it's a dual
effect of both the chemical fertilizer
and not using manure
it's also the dual effect of growing for
high yield but also the microbes
the the whole sort of environment in the
soil is so much more healthy which
allows the plants to take up the
nutrients better from a regenerative
farm
and so um that's there's sort of like
those three primary factors
okay so if you're not able to afford
meat on a regenerative farm or if you're
not eating from a regenerative farm it's
more likely that you need to supplement
specifically magnesium or other minerals
as well
uh well the most nutrient depleted
mineral is actually copper
um in both vegetables and animal foods
so
in vegetables we've lost 75 percent of
our copper milk is
essentially 100 gone we've virtually
eliminated copper from from milk
um in dairy and cheese and about 55
reduction in animal foods with copper
from non-regenerative farms
so so copper's number one magnesium
would probably be number two
there are other nutrients as well that
are lower uh calcium boron
selenium vitamin c all sort of on the 20
range okay you talk a lot about selenium
i don't know anything about selenium and
i'm pretty sure most people it's not
mentioned that often so can we go into
selenium
and what it is and why you may need it a
little bit
sure the one thing i do want to touch on
before we
um sort of leave the regenerative farm
conversation because i think this is
important for people to know
is i think this is the solution
regenerative farming
for not only the health of our society
but also
uh from a sort of a carbon
sequestrant standpoint and so what i
mean by that
is that um traditional factory farm to
me
for every pound of meat that's produced
on a factory farm where these
where these animals are sort of in
confinement there is a
six pound not positive carbon
contribution so it's it's harming our
environment
whereas if you do uh something called
adaptive multipatic farming
where essentially you have um these
animals on pasture that
that graze on multiple paddocks and they
don't destroy the land
the soil is so much better at absorbing
carbon it's net negative
so for every pound of flesh produced
under a gender farm
there is a six pound net negative carbon
so it's actually good for the
environment and so
i think um i most people don't get that
most people don't understand that food
from a regenerative farm is actually
net carbon negative so sorry for the
tangent i just think that's a really
important
point so back to selenium um
so i think so i love telling this story
about selenium because i think it really
it gives a great example of how
important nutrients are for immunity and
this can
we can sort of use this to kind of segue
into the immunity fix too
is selenium was only really found to be
important because of
viral infections and essentially
what happened is there's a there's a rna
virus
and again coronavirus is an rna virus so
this is giving the relevance to the
story
called coxy virus and it generally only
causes like hand foot and mouth and kids
it's not very virulent
but if you are selenium deficient it
causes something called keyshawn disease
which leads to cardiomyopathy and
potentially death
so essentially if you are deficient in
just one nutrient selenium
it takes a non-virulent rna virus
and makes it virulent leading to
cardiomyopathy and you treat those
patients by just giving them
selenium so that goes to show you how
how our just one nutrient interacts with
our immune system
and may determine if you have a poor
outcome to a viral infection or not
wow that's scary um okay so two
questions from that
one how do you test micronutrients
properly because i know at least the
blood tests i used to get through a
doctor
they weren't as accurate as what i as
other tests i found so do you have
recommendations
there and then let's delve into just
because of the pandemic and what's going
on let's delve into
what people maybe should be taking um
for viral protection but let's start
with that testing thing first
sure so traditionally how you test
mineral status is you give an
oral dose and you see how much comes out
either in the urine
or you see how it's working in the body
so it's good either
for magnesium the gold standard is iv
magnesium load
because if you give an oral dose um
there could be issues with absorption
right and so if you do the iv you're
bypassing any
absorb absorption issues and you look at
and see how much comes out in the urine
and essentially if you're retaining
a certain percentage that is indicative
that your body is trying to hold on to
that mineral
and is deficient so that's how magnesium
works
because it's primarily regulated by the
kidneys but all minerals don't
necessarily function like that and of
course that's cumbersome to give someone
a dose of magnesium iv and see if
they're retaining it
over a 24 hour span in the urine now
essentially the cut off is
this hugely debated on what should
the body be sort of getting rid of when
you give that iv dose
and essentially healthy people are
eliminating
over 90 of the dose in the urine and so
if you're if you're retaining
typically over 10 that's suggestive of
some
minor magnesium deficiency particularly
if you're retaining
more than 20 and then it's definitive
like
absolutely you have magnesium deficiency
um
if you don't have any uh sort of kidney
issues that could affect the test
but if you are retaining 50 of that dose
you are very deficient in magnesium
now this more simple way to do it is to
actually look at the blood test
and look at the lower end of normal so
the prob
most people think blood tests are
terrible for minerals but they're
actually not when your body is depleted
the blood level will go down it just
won't drop to below normal
so if you look and you're in the low
normal range
and then you look at your 24-hour
urinalysis and magnesium is low
that's very indicative of magnesium
deficiency
so i don't have time to really go into
every single mineral because
you can see how complex it is just with
magnesium
um and so it's different for every
mineral and i haven't figured out
the best test for every single mineral
but i have looked at other ones as well
and it's it's extremely complex
so i think for the common person
it's going to be very difficult to know
are you deficient or not
and simply sort of hedging your bats by
making sure you're consuming a
well-balanced nutrient-dense diet is
probably
the best way and hedging your bots with
certain supplementation
um based on sort of the depletions that
could be occurring
or fixing any issues that could be
causing you to lose
that mineral so it's i guess it's
i wish i had a simple this one test is
going to tell you if you're deficient
but i don't
okay that's that's fair enough uh i was
doing and it would be interesting to
know what you think about this but i was
doing
through naturopath they were looking at
cellular levels
of micronutrients and that was it they
gave me more
information i don't know how much more
accurate was but they gave me a whole
bunch more information than i got
through my doctor
or those tests like what do you think
about those
so those tests haven't typically been
standardized against gold standard tests
like iv magnesium load and so until you
do that
the only blood test that has been is
mononuclear
blood cell magnesium so technically if
you wanted just a simple blood test
to know if you are magnesium deficiency
deficient
unfortunately it's a uh it's more of a
research tool but if they made it freely
available
mononuclear blood cell magnesium does um
reflect the iv magnesium load very well
so i would say if there if there was one
test you should use it's that
which is looking at the um the cellular
level of your mononuclear blood cells
and the magnesium content within
what's really interesting about
magnesium is is there's sort of two
forms in the body
you can have a normal blood level but
your ionic free
magnesium could be low and that's the
actual active form
is the um free unbound magnesium
and typically those cellular tests don't
tell you if it's ionic or if it's bound
magnesium and
a lot of people will have normal serum
levels but low ionic
magnesium yeah okay that's what i was
that that's
yeah that's what i thought uh and then
so then for
treating not treating viruses per se or
virus prevention like what what are the
minerals or
vitamins we should be looking at like
you said selenium
apparently is important for that so are
there specific ones people should just
be taking
without bothering with testing what do
you think
so i can't give prescriptive advice but
i can give you my thoughts on what
what i do yeah yeah i do take a
a selenium supplement um called solenoid
cell it's from yeast it's more of a
whole food selenium i have no
affiliation with this company i don't
make any money from them
um but i do take 200 micrograms every
single day and the reason why i do
is there's been at least three clinical
studies that have looked at
selenium replete so people who have good
selenium status
and they give them 200 to 300 micrograms
of selenium as a supplement each day
and those studies have shown that the
cytotoxicity of their natural killer
cells their t
cells improve and dramatically increase
and so i don't think because the upper
limit for selenium is 400 micrograms per
day and you really
there hasn't really been side effects
until you hit 800 micrograms per day
i i don't think that me consuming 200
micrograms of selenium is going to lead
to any
sort of overdose or toxicity so that's
one supplement that i do take
i do also uh utilize camu camu for
vitamin c so camu camu
is the second highest uh natural source
of vitamin c
comes from fruit and it's an it's a
powder it's a whole fruit extract
and so i do utilize that to sort of get
my vitamin c levels up to around a gram
per day
so i try to do like 500 milligrams of
vitamin c from that twice a day
um and then i also do take uh magnesium
pre
mainly from mineral water because it's
already ionized and it's already highly
bioavailable
so i do um that's sort of like my
supplement for magnesium if i do
want to improve like my activity for the
day and i want to sort of be
activate my brain i will take a a
magtiene
the other supplements that i take are k2
which is important for
anti-calcification properties um
i do also take well besides vitamins and
minerals i'll just stick to
cod liver oil which gives me vitamin a
and vitamin d
and i don't need as many supplements
though because i started integrating
organs meats and essentially i consume
those as a blend
of muscle meat plus some liver plus some
heart so the heart gives me coq10
the liver gives me copper folate a
little more vitamin a things like that
the other supplements well most people
it's very difficult to get manganese in
the diet
especially in carnivore because the only
sources are certain types of fish
which you'd have to consume about two
pounds per day or
muscles you'd have to consume about
three and a half muscles three and a
half ounces of muscles every single day
and i don't really know anyone um who
wants to do that on a daily basis to get
their manganese however i will say that
the the level that's needed might be
lower on a carnivore diet and we don't
really know so we need more studies on
if it's truly um if the need is the same
on let's say a standard american diet
and it's probably not
yeah yeah i'm going to be doing blood
work like
extensive blood work because i do it
every year just to post online in case
anyone's interested and obviously that's
just anecdotal but i'm mainly eating
i'm really mainly eating high fat muscle
meat and then occasionally
liver i have it is incredible the
difference between people even on the
carnivore diet because there are there
are some people i've seen
who don't do anything except for high
fat muscle meat and their folate is fine
and then other people who don't do
anything but high fat muscle meat and
their folate isn't fine and they need to
incorporate liver in and then they can
boost it up a little bit
but uh it's just it's interesting to see
so hopefully by the time this podcast
comes out my blood work will be out not
that that
you know definitively proves anything
but maybe i can figure out how to
test for manganese that'd be interesting
yeah that one would be interesting and
to be honest i really don't know of
i haven't looked into manganese and what
the best test would be so
yeah but there are there are um pro
proteins and enzymes that function on on
manganese so
uh there there are certainly research
tools that you can look at the enzymes
that are dependent on manganese and see
if they're functioning well or not
um or the proteins um like one way we
measure selenium is called
a selenoprotein p and so there are these
proteins that these um that are
dependent on these types of minerals
that you can measure as well oh man that
would be a lot of testing
a lot of testing it's interesting though
uh it is yeah very
okay why is it that i've heard and i i
don't do this
when i went carnivore i was having
really bad digestive problems and it
turned out it was a bacterial infection
which was
unpleasant uh but i cut salt for about
four months because i thought
i don't know what's bugging me and i'm
only eating two things so i'll cut one
of them
and it turned out it just made my food
taste not as good and
i didn't feel much different it was only
four months and then i
so i put it back and everything is it
may have affected my energy a little bit
but i've heard of some carnivores who've
been doing like the long-term people
who don't eat salt so what do you think
about that
so those people they're they're
definitely not
sweating on a frequent basis because if
they are if they're going into the sauna
on a frequent basis or if they're
exercising and sweating a lot you will
become depleted in salt incredibly
quickly so
i i would i would actually be very
shocked if there were carnivores that
were
um sweating a lot on a frequent basis
and weren't using any salt
um that that would certainly be
interesting okay unless they're getting
salt
um you know just through i mean they are
going to get some through their food
um especially animal foods are higher in
salt so it depends are they consuming
some processed meat which is giving them
salt and they're not quote unquote
adding it but they're getting some
so that would be interesting to know
okay so just just falling off of that
and i know that like
actual carnivorous animals are different
but why is it that
like why is it that herbivores for
instance
they really enjoy salt right you can
give them salt licks and things but
what happens to animals like tigers
like do they just their body just
operates differently and they don't need
the
salt or is there salt in what they're
eating or
yeah that's a great point so so i guess
if you look at it from an evolutionary
perspective we've
we sort of evolved on the savannahs of
africa so we lost our fur
we got bipedal and we had another
evolutionary advantage compared to any
other animal
and that is we um are able to sweat out
salt to cool
off now horses can do that but they
don't do it as well as humans and so
this allowed us to persistent hunt
uh animals in very hot temperatures so
most people don't know that lions
90 of their hunts and kills actually
occur at night
um because they typically like to sleep
in the shade during the day because they
cannot cool off like humans can
so essentially we developed this ability
to lose salt because it would allow us
to then cool off and persistent hunt
animals
which would they would overheat and then
we could
kill them and get the salt back by
consuming nose to towel
consuming all the salt within their
blood right and the interstitial fluids
or we would follow herbivores
to salt lex and we would just follow
those trails and i'm actually from
buffalo new york which is named
for the buffalo that used to go to the
giant salt lake
um in buffalo so so it's a little bit
different because
the reason why um i guess we have this
salt craving
and it's dependent upon how much we're
losing and it's controlled in the brain
and essentially that's sort of why i
don't like when people don't listen to
their salt cravings because it's so hard
wired in and it's so important that
our body actually knows how much salt we
need typically
oh that's that's really cool i might
make it that into a clip that wasn't
that was interesting i didn't know that
about the like
continual sweating i also didn't know
lions hunt at night
which is something i primarily they do
yeah and there was a recent documentary
about this where they actually utilize
these special cameras and we're looking
at lions at night and they're much more
successful at night
as well huh interesting there's three
topics that i haven't covered in any
podcast and i think oh yes okay
let's do that yeah i think it'll be
interesting so you let me know if you
like these topics one would be
should like a healthy young person
should they be afraid of getting
coronavirus
i think that's a huge um question that
even i kind of struggled with
the second would be dumask's work and
third was my thoughts on vaccines i've
never covered any of those topics
yes no those are huge let's do that okay
so i think so for me personally i was
struggling and i was sort of coming
at first um from a little bit of a
naive perspective i said i'm healthy i'm
young
i should get this virus because you know
and a lot of people are saying this too
that
we never used to hide from viruses we
would just let them run their course
right but the problem with that is is
that
you either die or you live when you when
you do that right you
you're essentially um but now we have
ways to
if you quote unquote hide from the virus
for a little bit and
and allow medications to come out
then that can potentially help you if
you get it and you're really struggling
and the the main sort of argument
that i hear a lot of people saying is
that well if you're under 40
years of age your chance of dying from
coronavirus
is like less than one percent so why
should you care
well the the reason why i think people
should care is because
20 of everyone who is being hospitalized
from cobed
is from the age group of 20 to 44 and 12
percent of all icu
um coveted missions are in that same age
group
so you may live but we shouldn't look at
it from a perspective of are you going
to live are you going
to die it should also be how
what's this potential harms that could
happen
and not only hospitalizations but also
these long covet haulers and i actually
know a few
young health professionals that are
still suffering long covid
after they've gotten it what are those
symptoms
essentially it's damage to the the lungs
particularly the the alveoli
and you're essentially not oxygenating
yourself very well so you're sort of
gasping for
air and you feel like you're always
short of breath and
you might not even be able to walk um a
certain distance without feeling short
of breath and so you have no energy
and this can go on for months and months
and months and in some people it hasn't
even gone away
in young people and what's really
interesting is
several cardiac mri studies have come
out in patients who have been
hospitalized with coved
and then they wait several months to see
if anything's wrong with their heart
so they do a cardiac mri and
50 to 80 percent of those people that
they've looked at have had
inflammation of the heart still ongoing
and so you live from
coved but it's different than the flu
it's
causing these long haulers and it's
potentially causing long-term
inflammation of the heart and we don't
really know what that means yet
so the reason why i said i was naive is
because we didn't have these type of
studies
at first but i think looking at it from
a broad perspective i think
people are justified to be afraid and
think of your children too we don't
really know most children do
clear the virus very quickly but we
don't have studies on children after
they're infected with covid looking at
their hearts if there's any potential
issues and could they develop
you know cardiomyopathies later on and
so
i think it makes sense it's smart that
we could utilize
technology and wait for potential
treatments to come out
before we just expose ourselves to covet
okay
my so i had and again this is just
anecdotal i had coveted in july
and i was quite concerned because i used
to when i was on immune suppressants i
would
and i was on immune suppressants but i'd
get bronchitis yearly for
months i was hospitalized for pneumonia
once
and i ended up in the hospital a number
of times with this bronchitis
um so i thought okay that's probably not
good for me
and i had i certainly caught the virus
my whole family did my kid did and it
was not
pleasant but we haven't we've had a
fleet you know a fairly okay time right
it was it
felt like to me it felt like a bad virus
so
these i start coughing in the middle of
that
um so these you said these younger
people ending up in the hospital like
how much of that is comorbidities how
healthy are these people
yeah that's a good question so two sort
of two things i want to address number
one
even back in february there was about
five different strains of coke
so what i'm what i want to tell people
is if you didn't have a hard time
well what strain did you have there's
many more than just five strains now
and the strain in wuhan when it first
came out is much different than the
strain that's going around currently at
least
that's what we think and so viruses
mutate all the time every year which is
why you constantly have to get a new flu
vaccine every year
because this coronavirus will constantly
mutate as well and it could be more
virulent next year and you could catch a
different strain and so there's a lot of
potential reasons why maybe you didn't
have an issue and it could be that
you're just metabolically healthy and
maybe it doesn't affect people who are
metabolically healthy
and you're absolutely correct and this
is the main point in the
in the book that i make is that if you
have
metabolic syndrome which is a
constellation of three
or more of the five following risk
factors high glucose high blood pressure
high waist circumference
high triglycerides or low hdl that
increases your risk
of ending up in the icu by four and a
half fold with coved
an increase in increase your risk of
dying by three and a half fold
so of course you know if you're
metabolically unhealthy that
that is primarily who it is affecting if
you are under 60 years of age
yeah well it's a tricky situation
because
especially in certain areas of north
america everybody's metabolically
unhealthy
so like you took i was in serbia and
there were people who ended up in the
hospital for sure but there were a lot
of people that
you know were fairly sick at home but
they were okay
but if you just look at the people there
visibly they look healthier
so it's tricky to figure out how how
much you
force people to isolate like i'm i've
been fairly vocally against that
because i don't like the i don't like
the government making a choice like that
but then you were dealing with
potentially
an unhealthy population and you you
can't manage the hospital numbers
right and that's the key with the united
states is the norm
is being sick and because that's the
norm we don't have good data on the
healthy people
yeah right so that and that and that's
really
a good point that you're bringing up and
100 percent
metabolic dysfunction is going to
increase the morbidity and mortality
from covet
and sort of the next topic that i wanted
to cover
which is really interesting and it's
probably the most debated
is should people should there be
lockdowns and should people wear
masks yeah yeah right and if you look at
the countries that are doing the best
like sweden and japan they didn't do
full lockdowns but what they did do is
they targeted
super spreaders so kova 19 is different
than influenza in that
influenza seems to generally affect the
global population whereas
sars cove 2 there are super spreaders in
hot spots and essentially
20 of infected people are infecting 80
of those that get infected and
essentially what's happening
is and this is what sweden did is
the main driver of these outbreaks is
indoors with poor ventilation having a
lot of people indoors with poor
ventilation
people that have not been wearing their
masks in those indoors
poor ventilation and then people if you
add on top of this speaking loudly or
singing as in weddings churches because
you are projecting the virus out
consistently the studies show that that
is where these
coven 19 outbreaks are coming from the
majority of the time and so that's what
sweden and japan
actually went after they didn't do full
lockdowns they didn't lock down all the
businesses
they said essentially in sweden
they limited the cap to 50 people
indoors
in where other european countries were
becoming lacks sweden cut that cap
and also they took all high school and
college students
virtual because high school and college
students are likely to still go out to
the bars if they're feeling a little
sick
and so that's another quote-unquote
super spreader so it's really
interesting that covet 19
is primarily being driven by these super
spreading events and it's essentially
where you have a really sick person with
a high viral load
inside of let's say a church or a bar
they just infect
so many people and that's why contract
uh
uh contact tracing going retrospective
and looking back
works really well at finding out where
these sort of hot spots are coming from
that's kind of interesting that seems
like a better
yeah it's so funny uh in toronto at
least
because it's getting cold they made it
they
you can't do indoor dining so they got
rid of indoor dining even though
technically at least it's ventilated and
so they're like okay you can go on the
patio but it's cold here so they put
tents up on the patio
so now we have heated tents on the patio
instead of going indoors where there's
ventilation it makes
well now there's now they've closed down
everything so everything's closed down
but for you know a number for a month or
so there there were just these outdoor
unventilated tents instead of going
inside
right people are confused yeah and i
think it does that
so universal lockdown for covet doesn't
really make sense because it's
it only makes sense if you have a very
highly virulent
virus um like we would all be
wanting lockdowns if the bird flu which
has currently has a 60
mortality rate actually got throughout
the united states and there's been
very close encounters in hong kong where
this almost oh my god
that's terrifying multiple times yeah
the world health organization has had to
kill millions of birds multiple times
because it almost jumped to humans in a
very transmittable way
if that happens we're all going to be
inside
in lockdown but so lockdowns do
technically work you're not going to get
a virus if you're not in contact with
someone so there but
there's these conspiracy theorists that
say lockdowns don't work well
how else are you going to get the virus
if if you know what i mean if you're not
getting it from someone else lockdowns
do work
but in this particular case for economic
reasons
and it's not the best case you we
probably should be targeting those super
spreading events
like sweden and japan did which they're
why they're doing so well
now the question is is do masks work and
so
i tried to look at the actual studies
from both meta-analyses
and actual clinical studies themselves
and the reason why they're such a big
debate
is become is because some studies say
they do work and some don't
and we don't technically have a study on
cloth masks
in kovacs yeah so this the studies are
looking at people with influenza
or they're looking at um calming cold
or um you know other coronaviruses that
cause common cold besides rhinoviruses
so the problem though is that
if you have some studies that
consistently show benefit
and then you have studies that don't
you're kind of like well what the heck
like does it work or doesn't it work and
this is why we have the divide
and the reason though that you can
sometimes have studies that show benefit
and some that don't it's very easy to
get a negative result
if you don't do one thing correctly you
can get a negative result
it's very difficult to have a positive
trial
and then replicate it multiple times
which masks have been shown to do but
then you have the other studies where
they didn't work
but if you look at the reasons why they
didn't work most people weren't wearing
them
even half the time they weren't wearing
them correctly
and were they social distancing too and
so all these factors
come into play and then if you look at
the actual observational studies of
what's going on
it's the people that are indoors not
wearing masks
singing or talking loudly where these
outbreaks are occurring
it's not in places where they're wearing
masks so that's not causation
but it it backs up the positive clinical
studies
and we need to be understanding of why
certain studies fail
and just with us like a supplement if
you don't use the right dose it's not
going to work
and that's why some studies show
supplements work and some don't same
thing with masks so in my opinion
masks have a role for preventing super
spread of coronavirus
in my opinion and the other big
misconception
is that people are saying you should
only wear a mask if you're symptomatic
the problem with that is is that you can
spread the virus
two and a half days prior to being
symptomatic and
fifty of transmittable cases come from
the pre-symptomatic face
so that so the people that are saying
why are why is everyone wearing a mask
if they don't have symptoms
you sh you should be wearing a mask if
you don't have symptoms because of
the the data that i just said right
there that you can spread it without
being symptomatic
okay so what about so i'm not i like i
honestly don't nobody likes wearing it i
don't know why there's an
argument about whether or not it works
because because
obviously like there's a reason doctors
wear masks
during surgery right like um but
what about so there's a whole there are
a whole bunch of things that i think
people aren't talking about and because
enough time hasn't passed we don't have
any data
on so the negative effects i mean we
already talked about lockdown a little
bit
about some of the negative effects of
lockdown but what about something like
and and maybe it's less important but
what about something like
going around seeing visually
seeing people in masks all the time and
not being able to get the kind of
contact that we're used to because i
know it feels
me like it's uncomfortable right people
are getting a little bit more used to it
but it's uncomfortable trying to talk to
somebody in a mask
because it's a i think it's a bit scary
in an evolution
way or something i'm not i'm not saying
that properly so
um i'm not necessarily saying
it doesn't work because obviously it's
gonna work but what about these naked
potential negative consequences of being
in a society where everyone's
face is half covered you can't see
facial expressions and things
well that might actually be one of the
benefits of face masks
is that from an evolutionary perspective
what you're saying you don't want to
talk to someone you
it almost socially a lot of the time and
we're thinking this is what we're part
of the benefit is coming scares people
so they're following so i'm wearing a
mask and you stay away from them
and that may be where some of the
benefit is coming from because we know
for a fact
that social distancing to an extent does
work
it the the one thing that the news isn't
covering
is the six foot rule doesn't work when
you're in a poorly ventilated
area and so you know
it's a lot of people think well if i'm
six feet away that's fine well that
might be fine if you're outdoors but if
you're in a poorly ventilated area then
that
that rule sort of sort of goes away but
i do get what you're saying i
don't like wearing a mask i mean i don't
think anyone would argue and say
i prefer wearing a mask versus not i've
heard that a little bit
people who don't want to end up people
looking at them they're like ah this is
easier i don't have to shave anymore
yeah you're going to have some of those
people right that actually will prefer
wearing a mask
but but the vast majority right do not
like wearing a mask and i think it's
it's un-american too right to have any
type of
uh restriction or any type of mandate
that you have to do something with your
body so
i get why people don't like masks um but
i have to stick with the science i just
have to
yeah i i guess
i don't know the masks outside thing but
anything i'm just
i'm a paranoid i'm a paranoid person and
i'm always concerned that
if the government starts mandating
things there isn't going to be an
end and i just read an article um that
one of the airlines in australia like
one of the major airlines i think
australia and new zealand just said if
you don't we were going to get into
vaccines anyway
but if you don't have this vaccine
you're not allowed to
ride in our airplane and they do
international flights out of i think
australian
new zealand i think it's called qantas
kansas or something but so they're
already saying you can't come in unless
you have proof that you've had this
vaccine done
so and then so i'm just concerned like i
don't know where it stops and i don't
trust the government
yeah well well so to not confuse you i
i i'm not a fan of masks outdoors
because that's good ventilation
ah okay okay i'm only talking about
wearing a mask to stop the super
spreading events
which is an indoor event highly crowded
gotcha
and and that's where i think masks have
a a real role to play
i don't think if you're outdoors to me
it makes no sense to to wear a mask if
you're able to be six feet from someone
because
now you're getting rid of the poor
ventilation aspect so i hope that
okay okay yeah that's my stance yeah
yeah that definitely clears things up so
it's
get rid of the super spreaders and yes
and yeah and so we should be focusing
especially on
on ventilation which i don't think
anybody has really
mentioned right right and i mean that's
how they treated 1918 spanish flu they
brought everyone outside
um to get sunlight to breathe fresh air
and
it's it's kind of funny we're sort of
learning like the old natural ways
there was actually some good science
behind doing those types of things yeah
that's not surprising at all so that's
what they did
during the spanish flu and the spanish
flu was far more
deadly right yeah killed anywhere from
and we
because it was over a hundred years ago
we don't have good data but
the estimates are anywhere from 50 to
100 million people died
from spanish jesus and and is that the
one that hit
it hit young healthy people more
or is that wrong so you're not
necessarily wrong um you weren't
protected
per se if you were between 20 and 40.
you still
people that were above 50 still had
worse outcomes
um but the people that are quote unquote
have the least
hard time with coved 20 to 40 typically
they also had high rates of mortality as
well
not as high as like old people that were
older but they weren't really that
protected and so
we're the thing i mean thinking about
this from from beyond just a
a coronavirus perspective we're always
going to be dealing with any
any type of rna virus and
it that's the key point is that certain
viruses even being metabolically healthy
might not necessarily save you and could
potentially make things worse if it
tricks your own healthy immune cells
into killing itself
and so essentially that i i do cover
certain supplements in the book that
have potential for
you know inhibiting that type of you
know harmful effect from
you know those types of viruses okay
let's let's get into
vaccines and i want to start with like a
question about my concern
so my concern about getting a vaccine
that's produced this quickly
would be that we don't have time to look
at long-term effects so what if it
causes
and i know i know they do studies on
rats and all this but what if it causes
some sort of fertility issue
like i i know that the gardasil vaccine
ended up being a little weird
for some people and it caused
infertility issues that we didn't know
about and so this is one
that's rushed so i'm concerned it's
coming out fast right so i'm concerned
about that i'm concerned because there
are these mandates
in some areas wear masks outside that
there's going to be a blanket everybody
needs to get it
right and i understand people who want
it i understand people who are at risk
and uh inoculating them but i'm
concerned
like i don't think that they'd mandate
that but i don't know given what's going
on so those would be
like my major concerns about the vaccine
so what are your thoughts about it
yeah i think from like a broad
perspective
we're dealing with a a a virus that is
very good at mutating
and so i want people to understand that
a vaccine
for a rna virus is never going to be a
silver bullet
in almost every case i mean this is a
new type of virus right and so
it is using messenger rna to produce the
spike protein
um however uh the virus can change its
spike protein
and so okay you need to understand right
you're always gonna need uh you're gonna
have to shift
and and try to get the strain for every
year after year it's not like this is
you get it and then you're never gonna
have to do a coronavirus account so
that's
one thing that people need to do that's
a problem right
that is again that's a problem with
these types of highly mutatable viruses
um the other i guess issue
is that i am unaware of any type of
animal study where they've given these
type of messenger
rna back vaccines right to
animals and then have infected them with
the actual virus and proven
that this animal does not get the
disease or does not get any type of
adverse outcome from the virus and
ultimately
that is really the only way to prove if
a safe way to prove i mean obviously
you'd have to do it in humans too to
truly know but we're not gonna do that
to really know if a virus works because
there have been
uh similar rna vaccines um
against rna viruses where you develop
antibodies you look
okay you're you're looking like it's
effective and then
you give this virus to an animal and
actually infect them with the virus and
they die from
the virus in other words it looked good
on paper
oh my god it actually made the virus
worse because there
there's apparently two different types
of antibodies that the body can produce
there's neutralizing and then there's
binding
and the neutralizing antibodies are good
the binding antibodies can potentially
make
a virus worse so i'm unaware of those
animal studies if there are but i think
we
we and i know it's a trying time right
now because everybody wants a vaccine
but i think we almost
should demand that there needs to be an
animal study proving that
that giving them this vaccine uh will
prevent
any clinical disease once you give them
the actual virus
i'm a little bit surprised that there
hasn't been one
i don't think there has i'm not i'm not
saying there hasn't i'm unaware of any
study that has been done showing this
jesus and
and i haven't looked in depth so i won't
say that there isn't
but what this what the studies are doing
in humans
and like pfizer right and all these
other companies that are producing these
vaccines
they're simply testing if there's less
positivity rates yeah those who got
vaccine versus not that's what i've
heard
yeah if you get it you're you're not
going to have a
poor outcome right that we don't really
know what that really means
guess we'll find out yeah i guess we
will
oh man okay i didn't see that
conversation going that
in that direction oh yeah i i have done
a bit of research
about it i don't think most of the
people watching this episode actually
um just judging from my audience are
very excited about
the virus right like i think most people
are kind of in the healthier range and
a little bit more concerned about the
vaccine then
um then eager to get it um which is but
i
i think during the rollout in the states
anyway the people who are going to be
inoculated first are the people at risk
right that's the plan
that's the plan and i don't i don't want
to be like you know super down now about
vaccines because vaccines can work we
know that they can eradicate things like
polio and other things
it's just when you're dealing with a
mutating virus
they're much less effective than you
know
highly than other viruses that don't
mutate
as as much as rna viruses yeah
interesting
okay great uh let me think i have
i have a few more questions i have a few
more questions
oh yeah this is one this has nothing to
do with what we were talking about but
uh i've wanted to learn about it
bdnf what is that and how do you
increase it i've been reading a little
bit about it so let's just
fill my audience in on that yeah so so
uh bdnf stands for a brain derived
neurotrophic factor
most people call it fertilizer for the
brain and essentially it can help grow
new neurons um and you know it's
we didn't used to think that you could
do this we we thought
sort of you're you're born and once
you're at a certain age you have a
certain set of neurons and then
um essentially they just go down from
there and that's what leads to cognitive
decline but there are
things that people can do to increase
bdnf
and potentially increase the number and
function of their neurons
and so uh some things uh there's
definitely some supplements that have
been shown to do this uh
um well i mean magnesium alternate for
one uh
has been shown to increase synaptic
density
functionality plasticity and the
synapses are how neurons communicate and
really it's the loss of synapses
that leads to cognitive decline because
it's less connections in the neuron
itself
and bdnf may actually help with those
synapses as well
but even listening to music has been
shown to increase bdnf which is kind of
interesting
um sauna may increase bdnf through
hormetic type of
of a response certain plant polyphenols
may help
boost bdnf things like omega-3s
as well from things like wild salmon
seem to increase bdnf
so it's uh it's interesting that we
might have interventions that can
improve our own cognition
yeah okay you talked a little bit
earlier that about you taking cod liver
oil
how do you ensure that your cod liver
oil isn't rancid because i know if
you're swallowing rancid cod liver oil
that definitely isn't beneficial and a
lot of people do that
right yeah so i i mean i have no
affiliation with this company but um
it's rosita oh yeah yeah the one i use
and because of their very light
extraction process and they do measure
if there's any lipid peroxidation which
is essentially is the oil oxidized or
not
and you're 100 right most cod liver oils
on the market are probably highly
oxidized so
that is an important aspect that people
need to think about
with any omega-3 supplement i used
rosita
before i went to the carnivore diet and
then i cut out like
everything just to figure out what was
going on but i used rosita because they
were
yeah they had all that testing and there
were no other ingredients i know
some of the cod liver oil i was looking
at had other oils added as well
that i didn't want to be ingesting so
rosita did look pretty good
okay cool um and then
earlier you mentioned copper a little
bit so
for people on low carb diets or on
more you know carnivorous diets
do we get enough copper what is it for
like you don't really
hear a lot about copper i thought people
had too much copper but maybe
maybe that's wrong well a lot of the too
much copper is from people losing the
ability
to move copper around in the body from
metabolic dysfunction you start
having increases in iron and copper
even in alzheimer's yeah you start
losing the ability to move
um your minerals around so a lot of
times copper overload
is actually due to metabolic dysfunction
um
and so so copper and i don't want to
just single out copper there are
potential nutrients of concern
for carnivore and so calcium would be
one magnesium
um manganese boron for anyone really
and um in copper is another one unless
you're sourcing from oysters or liver
typically
and like like i mentioned copper is the
most
nutrient depleted mineral from foods
from non-regenerative farms
in both plant and animal foods so it is
a nutrient of concern and uh
we've published a couple papers on the
importance of copper
and essentially um you cannot move
iron around in the body without copper
so any
so we're even thinking that a lot of
iron deficiency anemia
is has nothing to do with not getting
enough iron it's actually due to the
inability to utilize
and move iron around in the body because
you're actually copper deficient
um because copper oxidizes iron
to a certain form to allow it to bind to
transferrin so we can move it around in
the body so copper has this
very important ability to allow us to
export
iron out of the liver and move it around
in the body so we so we can have these
um you know important needs for iron
mats
and what's really interesting about
copper is
most people know we lose a lot of salt
through swat but copper is another
mineral that we actually
uh lose a lot okay so
the average loss in um an hour
in the heat is about 0.4 milligrams
which is essentially
half of your entire dietary allowance
for copper you can lose in just one hour
in the heat
and most people are consuming right
around that range
of just under a milligram of copper
which is like your basic
your bare minimum just uh not slowly
become depleted and die of copper
deficiency like most people are
literally on that threshold
and so if you start sweating a lot and
not replacing the copper
that's how people get into some issues
with copper deficiency
okay interesting i have one last
question about salt that um i get asked
a lot and it's
what what happens to people who are
prone or have
heart disease or kidney disease and
should they be avoiding salt or having
more
salt and what's the danger of salt
consumption specifically for those guys
yeah so i guess um so if you're talking
about someone with heart failure let's
say which
which is the typical population where
they tell you to consume a low salt diet
which again
you know most guidelines tell those
individuals to
even go less than a half a teaspoon of
salt per day so they're very restrictive
most of these people 25 actually have
low sodium levels in their blood
and they're most of them are on a
diuretic that causes them to lose salt
and so if you go too low
the studies have shown that if you go
below 2 800 milligrams of sodium which
is
which is like a one in a third teaspoon
of salt you go below that
um that might actually be worse than
a normal salt intake because you're
you're essentially in heart failure your
volume overloaded which is dropping your
sodium levels
and so if you go too low not only is
your sodium level going to go down even
further
but it if the salt actually helps the
diuretic work it's
in your in the diuretics there to get
rid of all the fluid not really
the overloading salt and so having a
normal amount of salt
increases blood perfusion to the kidney
and allows the diuretic to get to the
kidney and the site of action where it
needs to go
to get rid of the extra fluid so the
clinical studies actually show
that a normal salt intake is probably
better for
those types of individuals and they even
treat heart failure patients
um who are going into acute kidney
failure because they're not getting
enough salt with hypertonic
so like very salty saline solution to
allow the diuretic to work better
so that's one common misconception
actually that population that we thought
would benefit the most of actually may
actually have the most harms from low
salts
and then for kidney dysfunction it sort
of depends
on the type of kidney disease some
kidney disease you spill a lot of salt
out because
you damage the ability to reabsorb salt
so what's really interesting is
we are essentially salt filtering
machines our kidneys filter
a full teaspoon of salt every five
minutes so eating uh eating a teaspoon
of salt
actually is not a high load on the
kidneys at all it's actually a relief on
the kidneys
because they have to filter and reabsorb
all of the salt that they filter
throughout the day and it takes a
tremendous amount of energy to do that
so if you just consume more salt it's
less
energy to reabsorb that salt back into
the body
and so it depends on the kidney disease
if you if you have kidney disease where
you're over retaining salt
then maybe a lower salt diet is
beneficial but if you have kidney
disease where you're losing salt
obviously more is better
okay great that was that was good i like
that i'm
i'm a huge fan of salt so this is this
is good for me good to hear
uh where where can people find you if
they want to find you online
so my website is dr james dineck.com
that's dinic
or on instagram or twitter at dr james
dineck
gotcha thank you very much for coming on
that was interesting i'm glad we got
into some covid talk i wasn't expecting
that
yeah it'll be it'll be interesting to
see what um what everyone thinks
another discussion especially around
masks i think i think that'll be a
a heavily divided uh group
yeah yeah we'll see i have faith in i
have well we'll see
my audience is pretty uh disagreeable
from what i've seen so we'll see what
happens but thanks again for coming on
yeah of course thanks for having me
you